* Regelmässiges Zischen *
(Frau) Gehen wir noch
auf den Balkon?
* Regelmässiges Zischen *
Draussen ist es sonnig.
In diesem Film
geht es um drei Familien,
die ein ähnliches Schicksal teilen.
Sie mussten sich
die für Eltern wohl traurigste
und zugleich brutalste Frage stellen:
Wie lange soll unser Kind noch leben?
Diese Frage mussten Sie sich stellen.
Zu welcher Antwort sind Sie gelangt?
Also, wie lange ...
Wir überlegen uns immer wieder,
was sie noch vom Leben hat.
Hat sie noch Lebensqualität?
Geniesst sie es noch?
Wir sagten immer: "Solange Liam
kämpft und solange wir sehen,
dass er noch will,
tun wir alles."
* Tiefer Seufzer *
Ja ...
Die Frage ist, inwiefern
man sie wiederbeleben soll.
Das ist ...
Es ist schwierig. Ich bin froh,
wenn wir nicht entscheiden müssen.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Mutter) Jetzt versuche ich mal,
einen Zopf zu flechten.
Das haben wir doch letzte Woche
bei jemandem gesehen.
Wir machen es so fertig. Zufrieden?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Gut.
Ich dachte nicht, dass du einen
so schönen Zopf flechten kannst.
Wie die meisten Teenager
legt Magali Wert auf ihr Äusseres.
Im Gegensatz zu Gleichaltrigen
ist sie dabei auf die Hilfe
ihrer Mutter angewiesen.
Die 15-jährige Magali
ist lebensbedrohlich erkrankt.
Sie leidet an Rasmussen-Enzephalitis,
einer seltenen Autoimmunerkrankung,
die das Gehirn schädigt.
Aus dem gesunden Mädchen,
das sie einmal war,
ist ein schwerstbetroffener Teenager
geworden - sowohl in kognitiven,
als auch körperlichen Fähigkeiten
eingeschränkt.
Im Frühling dieses Jahres
hatte Magali in der Badewanne
einen epileptischen Anfall
und tauchte unter.
Tagelang kämpfte das Mädchen
im Spital ums Überleben.
An einem Abend war es ganz kritisch,
als ihre Atmung
nicht mehr funktionierte.
Sie mussten dich
2 Std. lang beatmen
und benötigten spezielle Dinge.
Ich war allein in Zürich
und rief abends
Klaus und Killian an und sagte:
"Jetzt müsst ihr kommen."
Aber das hast du nicht gemerkt.
Davon habe ich keine Ahnung mehr.
- Genau.
Wir denken immer positiv.
Wir denken immer positiv, genau.
Positiv zu bleiben, hilft, was?
Mhm.
Ich finde es auch super, dass
ich sprechen und oft gehen kann.
Und du bist nun
auch an einen Rollstuhl gewöhnt.
Das klappt jetzt gut.
Anfangs wolltest du das nicht,
aber nun ist es ganz normal. - Mhm.
Familienausflug.
Zwar achten die Peters darauf,
dass Magalis Krankheit
ihr Leben nicht komplett dominiert,
doch Magalis Zustand
gibt regelmässig den Takt vor.
Mehrmals täglich
erleidet sie epileptische Anfälle.
Wie jetzt, auf dem Spaziergang.
Die Familie
hat sich längst daran gewöhnt.
Ist es wieder okay, Magi?
- Bist du wieder da?
Das war jetzt einer der epi-
leptischen Anfälle, die Magali hat.
Sie hat häufig kleine Anfälle.
Es ist nicht so, dass sie immer
hinfällt und aus dem Mund schäumt,
aber sie hat sie dafür sehr oft.
Ich schäume nicht aus dem Mund.
- Nein, das tust du nie.
Aber du bist manchmal abwesend.
Du hast eine Absenz.
Dann kannst du nicht mehr stehen
oder nicht sprechen.
Ich denke, es ist am besten,
wenn man einfach normal weitermacht.
Das ist auch ...
Darauf achten wir schon.
Ja, je nachdem
sind die Anfälle sehr häufig.
Manchmal phasenweise alle 5 Min.
- Ja.
Darum ist immer
jemand in deiner Nähe.
Wir lassen dich
eigentlich nicht allein.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Zischen der künstlichen Beatmung *
Die 13-jährige Ceren
daheim in ihrem Kinderzimmer.
* Sie spricht türkisch. *
Die Eltern sind sich sicher,
dass Ceren ihr Umfeld noch wahrnimmt,
auch wenn sie
nicht mehr sprechen kann.
Früher konnte sie noch
mit Gebärdensprache kommunizieren.
Aber jetzt geht das nicht mehr.
Wir verstehen sie
meistens wegen ihrer Blicke
und wenn sie traurig ist, weint sie.
Aber ... Ja.
Seit zwei Jahren pflegen die Eltern
ihre unheilbar kranke Tochter
zu Hause.
Sie soll dort sterben dürfen,
wo sie sich am wohlsten fühlt.
Ceren leidet seit
ihrer Geburt an Morbus Pompe,
einer seltenen,
neuromuskulären Erkrankung.
Schau, jetzt fallen
wieder Blätter runter.
Der Sommer ist schon vorbei.
- Ist die Sonne nicht zu stark?
Doch.
Zwar war Ceren durch ihre Krankheit
als Kind eingeschränkt,
nahm aber aktiv am Alltag teil.
Bis sie vor zwei Jahren
eine schwere Lungenentzündung erlitt.
Mittlerweile kann sich Ceren
nicht mehr bewegen,
muss künstlich beatmet
und ernährt werden.
Es geht ihr tendenziell
immer schlechter.
Die Eltern sind bemüht, ihre Tochter
ins Familienleben zu integrieren.
Sie ist eigentlich
immer mit uns zusammen.
Aber nach draussen
können Sie mit ihr nicht mehr?
Nein, zum Einkaufen oder so
kann sie nicht mit.
Ich gehe einkaufen,
wenn die kispex hier ist.
Aber abends ist sie immer
mit uns zusammen im Wohnzimmer.
Im Sommer, wenn es schönes Wetter
ist, sind wir auf dem Balkon.
Aber ansonsten
ist sie immer mit uns zusammen.
Das geniesst sie auch sehr.
Sie ist sehr gerne mit uns zusammen.
Auch wenn diese Momentaufnahme
mit Kaffee und Kuchen
und dem Besuch der Grossmutter
so friedlich scheint,
es ist ein Leben im Ausnahmezustand.
Für die gesamte Familie. Auch
für Cerens jüngeren Bruder Mehmet.
Dessen sind sich die Eltern
sehr wohl bewusst.
Keine Ferien,
keine Familienausflüge.
Nur selten
verlassen sie gemeinsam das Haus.
Ceren zurückzulassen,
fällt ihnen schwer.
Ab und zu mussten wir mitmachen,
wegen Mehmet.
Aber ...
... wir sind natürlich
viel öfter zu Hause.
Wenn ein Familienmitglied ausfällt,
nicht dabei ist,
kann ich das Ganze nicht geniessen.
Ohne Ceren.
- Nein.
Darum ist es
eine schwierige Situation.
(Mutter) Ich muss ihr
das Medikament geben.
Mehrmals täglich bekommt Ceren
starke Schmerzmittel verabreicht.
Körperliche Qualen sollen dem
todkranken Mädchen erspart bleiben.
* Die Mutter spricht türkisch. *
Schön.
Zur Kontrolle im Kinderspital Zürich.
Magali besucht
mittlerweile eine Sonderschule.
Die Krankheit wirkt sich
auch auf ihr Sozialleben aus.
Ich merke - du wirst wahrscheinlich
sagen, dass das nicht stimmt -
dass du etwas verwirrter bist
und Dinge
teils nicht so schnell verstehst.
Das ist etwas schlechter geworden.
Das Gehen ist dagegen viel besser.
Wie geht es dir sonst,
in der Schule?
Blöd ist einfach ...
... dass ...
... ich jetzt
nicht mehr in derselben Schule bin.
Mhm.
- Ich vermisse meine Freundinnen.
Manchmal fühle ich mich auch einsam.
- Mhm.
(Ärztin) Sie fehlen dir ganz arg.
Oh, das ist traurig.
Für eine umfassende Behandlung
Magalis sind sowohl eine Neurologin
als auch eine Palliativmedizinerin
zuständig: Eva Bergsträsser.
Sie begleitet die Familie.
Palliativbetreuung beinhaltet
auch die Auseinandersetzung
mit dem Sterben.
"Hauptsache,
mein Kind bleibt am Leben."
So der natürliche Reflex
der meisten Eltern.
Doch ist das tatsächlich
immer das Beste für das Kind?
Solche und ähnliche Fragen
gilt es zu klären.
Da es eine Sonderschule ist,
lassen sie sie schlafen.
Dass man z.B. auch fragt:
"Woran erkennen Sie,
dass Ihr Kind leidet?"
"Was macht
das gute Leben Ihres Kindes aus?"
"Was möchten Sie
Ihrem Kind zumuten?"
"Was denken Sie ...
... was Ihr Kind ertragen kann?"
"Was würde Ihnen Ihr Kind,
das sich jetzt nicht äussern kann,
übel nehmen?"
Ich glaube,
das kann dabei helfen ...
... solche Wünsche,
die manchmal recht global sind,
ein bisschen herunterzubrechen.
Was genau meint man eigentlich, wenn
man sagt: "Das Kind muss leben"?
Die Eltern reden offen
mit Magali über ihre Krankheit.
Das Thema Sterben
haben sie bewusst nur gestreift.
Sie wollen Magali keine Angst machen.
Die Eltern aber
mussten sich gezwungenermassen
mit dem Lebensende ihrer Tochter
auseinandersetzen.
Wenn sie z.B.
völlig immobil wäre und
sich nicht dazu äussern könnte ...
... müsste man halt
für sie entscheiden,
ob es für sie noch lebenswert ist,
und das ist ...
... schwierig.
Was sind für Sie
denn die wichtigen Punkte?
Also, für uns ist es eigentlich ...
Wir machen so viel,
wie Magali noch hilft.
Wenn man z.B. Massnahmen
zur Wiederbelebung treffen könnte,
Magali dadurch aber nichts gewinnt
und es ihr danach
schlechter geht als vorher,
dann lassen wir es lieber.
(Ärztin) Das darf ich haben? Wow!
Das sind ja lauter englische Namen.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ich komme nachher
auch nochmals kurz vorbei.
Ciao, Magali. Tschüss.
Was gilt im Notfall?
Eva Bergsträsser hilft Familien,
ihre Wünsche in Betreuungs-
vereinbarungen festzuhalten.
Ein längerer Prozess, in den meist
mehrere Personen involviert sind.
Doch am Ende sollen
die Eltern entscheiden können.
Extern irgendetwas zu initiieren,
kann höchst problematisch sein.
Denn die Eltern -
egal, was sie dazu antreibt,
etwas zu tun oder nicht zu tun -
müssen mit dem leben,
was dann passiert.
Wir sind auch ein bisschen
mitverantwortlich dafür,
wie es ihnen geht, wenn ihr Kind
gestorben ist, egal wie es starb.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Ihre Art der Verarbeitung.
Liam, der Sohn von Thomas
und Tiffany Wermelinger,
ist vor anderthalb Jahren verstorben.
Zur Erinnerung an ihn haben
die Eltern eine Ecke des Wohnzimmers
mit Liams Spielzeug dekoriert.
Auch seine Urne steht hier.
Liam war ja immer hier zu Hause.
Wir wollten sie
möglichst nahe bei uns haben.
Ich finde es auch schön,
ihm nach dem Aufstehen
quasi guten Morgen sagen zu können.
Er ist immer noch ein Teil von uns.
Er ist immer noch unser Sohn,
und das wird sich auch nie ändern.
Darum ist es schön,
jeden Tag daran erinnert zu werden.
(Liam) Hallo.
Schau mal, wie genau er ist.
- (Thomas) Was putzt du jetzt?
* Liam spricht unverständlich. *
* Lachen *
Liam war mit 18 Monaten
an Leukämie erkrankt.
Für den Jungen, aber auch für seine
Eltern begann eine intensive Zeit:
der Kampf gegen den Krebs.
Liam musste sich mehreren Behandlun-
gen unterziehen lassen - erfolglos.
Die Familie reiste in die USA.
Ihre letzte Hoffnung:
eine neuartige Immuntherapie.
Die Therapie ist nicht ungefährlich.
Das wussten die Eltern.
Der Krebs
verschwand zwar tatsächlich,
doch Liam wurde immer schwächer.
Er war ganz grau.
Aber gerade bei diesem Video
ist es eindrücklich,
den Wandel des Aussehens zu sehen.
Man sieht, was eine so schwere
Krankheit mit einem Kind macht.
Ja, was der Krebs, die Chemos ...
- Ja.
und all diese Medikamente
mit einem so kleinen Kind machen.
Das hinterlässt schon Spuren.
In dem Moment sieht man
das eigentlich nicht. - Nein.
Das realisiert man gar nicht.
Nein, man ist so im Moment gefangen.
- Nein. - Es geschieht schleichend.
Haben Sie sich nie gefragt:
"Können wir
vielleicht nicht loslassen?"
"Ist es vielleicht egoistisch,
so weiterzumachen?"
Nein, keine Sekunde lang.
- Nein.
Ich glaube, er gab vor,
wie weit wir gehen sollen. - Ja.
Er bestimmte, wie weit wir gehen.
Das bestimmte kein anderer.
Ich glaube, wenn wir gesehen hätten,
dass es gegen seine Interessen geht
und dass er leidet,
wären wir nicht so weit gegangen.
Ich glaube, er hatte den Kampfgeist.
Liam hat die Therapie nicht überlebt.
Er ist im Beisein seiner Eltern
verstorben.
Dann entfernten sie die Maschinen
und hängten alle Schläuche ab,
ausser den Schlauch
fürs Schmerzmittel.
Dieses dosierten sie relativ hoch.
- Das Beatmungsgerät blieb auch.
Und, ähm ... Er sollte auf
jeden Fall keine Schmerzen haben.
Den Rest entfernten sie.
Ja. - Dann legten wir uns
so zu ihm ins Bett.
Ja.
Wir blieben einfach bei ihm,
hielten ihn und waren für ihn da,
damit er nicht alleine war.
Und irgendwann schlief er dann ein.
- Ja.
Kämpfen bis zum Schluss. Doch was
ist, wenn Eltern das nicht wollen?
Können Eltern auf das Lebensende
ihres Kindes Einfluss nehmen?
Diese Entscheidung
können auch Eltern treffen.
Sie können sagen:
"Die Situation
ist zwar kontinuierlich stabil,
es wird nicht besser, sondern
tendenziell immer etwas schlechter,
daher wollen wir
die Beatmung nun langsam beenden."
Dann würden wir dabei helfen,
dass sie das tun können.
Diese Möglichkeit gäbe es?
- Diese Möglichkeit gibt es.
Es ist nie
eine spontane Entscheidung.
Sie wird
mit den Eltern langsam entwickelt,
wie alle solchen Prozesse.
Das ist wichtig.
Wenn Eltern das aus dem Affekt
entscheiden und wir handeln,
kann es sein,
dass sie eine Woche später sagen:
"Wir haben einen Fehler gemacht."
Deshalb gilt es,
das gut zu besprechen und zu sagen:
"Wir haben gemeinsam beschlossen,
dass es jetzt gut ist."
"Wir können die Therapie beenden."
Oder die lebenserhaltenden
Massnahmen.
Das ist es ja eigentlich.
Ohne diese Massnahmen wäre ein Kind
wie Ceren schon längst gestorben.
* Zischen der künstlichen Beatmung *
Hallo, Ceren.
Ich höre mir nun an,
was dein Bauch macht.
Visite der Palliativmedizinerin
des Zürcher Kinderspitals
bei Ceren zu Hause.
Momentan mache ich mir um den Bauch
keine Sorgen. Es sieht gut aus.
Danke, Ceren,
ich bin bereits fertig.
Hausbesuche ermöglichen der Ärztin,
sich ein Bild
von Cerens Zustand zu machen,
um anschliessend mit den Eltern
die nächsten Schritte zu besprechen.
An welchem Punkt sagen Sie:
"Jetzt nicht mehr"?
Gibt es diesen Punkt überhaupt?
Nein.
- Nein, diesen Punkt gibt es nicht.
Ich kann nicht sagen:
"Jetzt geht es nicht mehr. Schluss."
Wenn die Zeit da ist,
ist die Zeit da und ...
Dann können wir uns
von ihr verabschieden.
Aber wir können
nicht selbst entscheiden,
wann dieser Punkt gekommen ist.
Das können wir nicht tun.
Denken Sie, dass sie
noch Lebensqualität hat? - Ja.
Also, so wie sie durchhält ...
... wie sie kämpft ...
Das wundert uns alle sehr.
Der Wille ist noch da. Er ist
noch sehr stark. Das merken wir.
Ceren hat heute
ein bisschen gelächelt.
Das heisst für mich ...
... dass Ceren das Leben noch
geniesst, wen sie noch lächeln kann.
Für eine optimale
medizinische Versorgung Cerens
arbeiten die Ärztin
und das Team der kispex Hand in Hand.
Die Kinderspitex
Kanton Zürich unterstützt
und begleitet die Familie
während der sog. End-of-Life-Phase
und ermöglicht, dass Ceren
trotz komplex-palliativer Situation
daheim versorgt werden kann.
Zum Hilfsangebot gehört
auch die medizinische Überwachung
während der Nacht.
Jetzt heisst es Nachtruhe.
Es ist so viel passiert
und du bist müde.
Ja.
- Die ganze Familie ist müde.
Die Eltern möchten ihre Tochter
unbedingt bei ihrem letzten Schritt
begleiten.
Der Vater ist in Sorge,
er schaffe es von der Arbeit
nicht rechtzeitig nach Hause.
Meine Hoffnung ist,
dass ich dabei sein kann.
Äh ...
Es ist ein schwieriger Moment,
wenn das geschieht,
aber ich möchte
bei meiner Tochter sein.
Mein Wunsch ist,
dass unser Sohn nicht zu Hause ist.
Das ist das Wichtigste für mich.
Dass er es nicht miterleben muss?
- Ja.
Früher sagte ich immer, ich wolle
nicht alleine zu Hause sein,
aber nun denke ich eher, dass unser
Sohn nicht zu Hause sein sollte.
* Zischen der künstlichen Beatmung *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Die Palliativbetreuung
von Kindern und Jugendlichen
beinhaltet nicht nur das Sterben.
Es geht auch um Leben.
Möglichst viele gute Momente und Er-
innerungen schaffen - und zwar jetzt.
Willst du noch ein Geschenk?
Du wirst verwöhnt.
(Magali) Wow!
- Klar wirst du verwöhnt.
Magali feiert ihren 15. Geburtstag
zusammen mit ehemaligen
Schulkameradinnen,
die sie so sehr vermisst.
Tatsächlich gibt es für die Familie
weitaus mehr zu feiern
als nur ein weiteres Lebensjahr.
Du magst ja Tiere
und ich fand es einfach süss.
Für uns ist es
natürlich etwas ganz Besonderes.
Im Frühling dachten wir, Magali
komme gar nicht mehr nach Hause
oder sie komme
so schwer behindert nach Hause,
dass wir nicht mehr so Geburtstag
feiern können wie heute.
Nun können wir eigentlich
Geburtstag feiern wie immer.
Das ist wunderschön,
ein wirkliches Geschenk.
Die Kinder leben.
Dabei soll das Sterben
angesprochen werden
durch eine Behandlungsvereinbarung,
einen Reha-Status etc.,
aber dann ist das kein Thema mehr.
Dann geht es darum,
wie Magali heute mit ihren
Einschränkungen glücklich sein
und leben kann.
Es geht auch darum, wie die Familie
gesund bleiben, leben ...
und irgendwann
bereit dafür sein kann,
dass Magali vielleicht stirbt.
Gesundheitlich hat Magali
immer wieder Rückschläge erlitten.
Heute ist ein guter Tag, auch wenn
sich gegen Abend ihre Anfälle häufen.
(Freundin) Oh, das ist eine gute
Farbkombination. Das passt zu dir.
(Mutter) Nina, nimm die Schere weg!
- (Freundin) Ja. Ich halte sie.
Warte!
Jetzt ist es runtergetropft.
Magali, was hast du bekommen?
Was ist das Hellblaue?
Stifte etc., gell?
Wie ist das jetzt für euch?
Man muss einfach kurz warten,
aber das geht dann schon.
Ja.
- Da ist sie schon wieder.
(Nina) Es ist halt
schon total traurig,
dass es
ausgerechnet sie getroffen hat.
Und ... Niemand hat das verdient,
aber v.a. meine beste Freundin
hat das nicht verdient.
# (Alle) Happy birthday to you,
# happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday, liebe Magali,
Aber wenigstens
halten wir alle noch zusammen.
Ja, das ist das Schönste.
Kurz nach unseren Dreharbeiten
musste Magali
erneut notfallmässig ins Spital.
Zwar ist sie wieder zu Hause,
doch die Krankheit
schreitet immer weiter voran.